I see see that because these are the
main categories of sequence and series
that you're going to meet first in the
top and they're the easiest to deal with
so what plus ten plus five or seven when
there is a common difference we call
this kind of series and arithmetic
students that or an aesthetic sequence
that's a really important phrase on that
put in capitals arithmetic as the
sequence or an asthma series one more
word I hate that I'm putting so much
language on you but I want you to
recognize it in the future
one word that catches both sequences of
zeros is a progression you're going
forward in someone so we would call this
an Advent progression and Amy this is
also an APU
you can have all kinds of different
Advent progressions all the ones we've
been looking at they get bigger and
bigger and bigger but if you get ones
that gets smaller and smaller so for
example let's go with something like say
seven for one so this is three terms
I've established a pan I could say dot
dot dot but can you tell me what the
next term will be maybe to negative five
F dot dot dot so you can keep on going
forever if I wanted to
so the I'm going to give you a question
now to help you wrap your head around
this idea of Luthor right you guys know
that this series comes in at once that
perceive this how many of you did gasps
yes
again as a small number so yes very
famous mathematician
here is prove this problem which you put
your pen down listen to the problem and
then solve it together okay I shall let
you solve the first thing to talk about
as a young schoolboy so the story goes
our gas was very great mathematics so
his teacher wanted him to just kind of
put a bit a corner and sort of get it
out of the way because there's always
like asking questions and he was doing
it too quickly so the teacher thought I
know what I'll do I'll give them the
task that will take you ages and then
he'll be at least a Q PI for a long time
and I know he likes mathematics so the
teachers had to ok Gauss what I need you
to do little Karl is I want you to add
up the numbers one to one you just add
them all up 1 2 3 4 5 etc ok and then
come back to me 10 minute and give me
the final answer okay and to teachers
dismay just instantly replied the answer
is I can tell you what nutrients but I
want you to try and work out first this
app data creation here is a common
difference of two okay the arithmetic
progression that Gauss's teacher gave it
had a common difference of 1 so you
could set it in any of these ways I want
you to ponder for a moment what might be
an efficient way rather than just 1 plus
2 is 3
to your 5 etc what might be an efficient
way to add up all the numbers 100 or
even because once you've worked it out
there we eat in generalize once your
thousand or 1/2 a million I would give
you a couple minutes if you actually
can't do something for it go ahead and
write down the solution and call me up
all right let's have a look
surface maybe a sketch in your hand a
little bit and some of you have an
advantage you're going to because you
see something like this before so here's
what I'm going to do to subject AP the
30 that might be helpful it's just to
write what the thing is
so we said 1 plus 2 Plus 3 that's enough
to establish a pattern so plus dot dot
dot the dot indicates the continuation
but this one that I'm given to you or
that the teacher gave to Galus is finite
so there's an endpoint at some location
and statement I could just say I 100
that that would be fine because I know
how I start how I go and how I
but for the purposes of doing this to
sum that up I'm actually going to add a
few more terms
whoops okay so that's the entire series
written in some form
so what can I do here well what gauss
did was he said this symmetry do you
notice this symmetry here as you get
bigger and bigger and bigger going from
left to right that means you also get
smaller as well as more going to
right-to-left
yes that and because it's a common
difference of doing the same thing just
in Reverse so therefore it says to read
if you have a look at the first term in
the last and you take their sum as you
move inwards from the outside this term
will be one bigger than the previous one
so this one is like plus one right but
this one will be one that's smaller than
the other one we just chosen from minus
1 right so the possum the minus 1 should
balance out which is why sure enough
these some to 101 and these sub to 101
right is the same plus 1 minus ones that
stayed about and you can keep this going
forever right so therefore you can work
out if you pair up every time with it
sort of opposite 1 on the end right if
you pair up every turn then they all Sun
to 101 all the pair's so all your
anything's know is how many pairs of it
there is going to be exactly 50 pairs
because there's a hundred numbers in
total okay so you just have to take the
somebody's here find out how many pairs
and then off you go over there is your
answer okay now what that positions are
always searching for is a way to
generalize this how can we go through a
specific example to one that works all
the time
it was a thousand or a million well what
it's become a difference wasn't one that
was very convenient what if it was like
three will find four to the quarter or
negative x okay so we write this in a
more general form so a generalized 18 as
the progression will look like this
there are the two numbers you need you
need a starting point which is the first
number let's use the first letter in our
house better alert it a and then you
need to know the common difference that
gets you from one to the next so if I
said since it's a different that's
called Z for different it a is the first
term what's the second term it will just
be this plus your common difference
you're great that's it that's the third
7 AG second term what will the third
term be a plus another what of that
difference right this is the third time
I've established I've established a
pattern right that's all I'm people
eventually we're going to get to the
last term right if this is a finite
series so do you notice the first term
has how many differences there none
the second term has how many differences
the third term has so you've always got
one less than the number of terms you
are so this is ten one and turn to enter
three and if I have some arbitrary
number of terms in terms right how many
core differences will that guy have
one less which is n minus one oh okay
so therefore the very large sample of
the MTN will be you start somewhere
and then you have to add some number of
those differences as you keep going so
that is number of differences that okay
right so now we can work out using this
we can apply the same strategy right 101
100 of 1 where did another cop remember
it was the sum of the first and last
term's right the first of Munson's so in
this case the sum of the first and last
term's is going to be a plus a plus n
minus 1 d so okay so I can simplify that
to a box like that that's the sum of the
first and last time then I had fifty
twenty fifty come from what two
significance of it
okay so I could say it's the last time /
- the reason why it's the last time / -
is that I am carry on
is it having care there are right so
that the operation gives is not one and
the way to find out how many pairs the
rows to divide that by two right
or rather divide the number of terms you
have which in this case by two just
conveniently in our previous example the
land above was having two there are okay
it's the formula now what's really
lovely about this more card is that it
actually solves a problem which we
didn't even discuss before which was
synesthesia conveniently you can pair up
every time parity argument but it
doesn't take much to create a problem
where you can't tear erything up
what could I do to this what subtle
change could I make that would make this
unbearable how many terms are there here
there's an even number of pairs a
hundred often so all I have to do to
make it unbearable is add another number
right like that now my question to you
is will this work will this approach
still work have a look at this formula
right now because we already know what
the first I have to add up to you it's
not hard to work out what the first 101
add up to I want you to have a go for a
second and evaluating this this is this
formula we've development because the
sum of the first n terms rather than I'm
calling it TN we would call it SN
have a go evaluating that's always a
down the bottom there
you know the first tip is you know what
the number of terms is and you know what
the common difference is try it out for
this guy here this is going to here if I
went a little bit further what would
happen so soon